[Music]
please watch sundar Pichai
[Applause]
welcome to next thank you all so much
for joining us I think we're being
joined by many many people on the
livestream as well so thanks to all of
them for joining as well it's been a
really exciting humans for Google cloud
in March one of our cloud developer
advocates Emma Haruka evolve broke the
Guinness world record for calculating
thirty one point four trillion digits of
pi that was my reaction as well when I
first started she did by running Google
compute engine continuously to read 10
petabytes of data it really shows the
reliability of the product I'd hope to
read the whole number out here but I
don't think I have enough time for it
for those of you who follow college
basketball last night was quite a game
google cloud has a great partnership
with the n-c-double-a and this year we
invited some college student developers
to join in the fun they helped us make
some predictions using 80 years worth of
basketball data and some of the
developers are astute here today our
future CIOs and CTOs let's give them a
round of applause
[Applause]
thank you for being here you've helped
us take office practice to an entirely
new level at Google and trust me you
don't want to be in a pool with Thomas
Korean at Google nothing excites us more
than solving a problem except maybe
solving a problem at scale we've always
had the ambition to use technology to
improve the lives of as many people as
possible and enterprise gives us an
opportunity to approach this in a
profound way by directly working
together with companies businesses and
institutions that power our global
economy and drive important changes in
our society cloud is one of the largest
areas of investment for Google as a
company so we are truly on this journey
with you together and we are in it
for the very long term we want to make
sure we are a great technology partner
to all of you I'd like to talk to you
about three areas today growing our
world-class infrastructure bringing
innovative technologies to everyone and
building open ecosystems to help your
businesses thrive for over 20 years we
have been scaling our technology
infrastructure to match the growth of
information we continue to invest in the
infrastructure that made Google
successful and that now powers Google
cloud our custom server hardware and
data centers can bring an enormous
amount of computing power to people all
over the world we are in over 200
countries and territories connected by
hundreds of thousands of miles of
fiber-optic cable in fact we recently
laid our own cable under the Pacific and
now we are doing the same under the
Atlantic we have 19 cloud regions and 58
data centers slide and today I'm excited
to tell you that we're bringing two new
locations on line one and Seoul and one
in Salt Lake City
[Applause]
just to give you a sense of scale in a
fun way six years ago our data center
capital plan included about two Eiffel
Towers worth of steel this year's plan
includes enough steel to build 20 Eiffel
Towers that's a whole lot of steel
it shows the scale of our infrastructure
regardless of the business you're in we
want to help you use the most advanced
technologies to drive innovation it's an
incredible time to be developing cloud
technology and using it to solve
problems whether it's using AI to help
ships navigate safely connecting offline
and online retail with personalized
experiences or using machine learning to
help financial institutions detect fraud
we know these solutions are only helpful
to your business if they are fully
accessible and easy to use that's why we
are scaling up our team so we can spend
more time with you understanding your
most important opportunities and it's
been exciting to see the momentum we are
building today together in fact today
Google cloud is working with most of the
top 10 companies across media and
entertainment and retail and half of the
top 10 financial services firms as well
as many other sectors and industries we
are grateful for our partners who are
helping us extend our reach and make our
customer successful Thomas is going to
be sharing a number of new and important
customer and partner announcements over
the coming days google also has a 20
year history of building truly open
ecosystems for everyone and we want to
do the same for enterprise computing
today most of the world's enterprise
computing still happens on premise it
doesn't know to the cloud yet because
the path forward is complex and daunting
and full of difficult decisions how do
you modernize in place without having to
jump completely to the cloud
Brij incompatible architectures Wiley
transition and how do you maintain
flexibility and avoid locking we have
faced similar challenges as a company in
her own business the mass of resource
requirements of her own cloud services
bead search maps and Gmail demanded
every ounce of computing power from our
servers but we needed to maintain
flexibility to adapt to shifting user
demands and we really wanted to be easy
to ship between jobs this led to our
early experimentation with cluster with
containers and we developed their own
internal cluster management tool
Borg and as we develop Google Cloud we
wanted everyone to be able to use Borg
for their computing needs and the result
was our open-source effort kubernetes
today it is the industry standard for
running and managing containers and last
year we announced the cloud services
platform to allow you to manage
kubernetes both on Prem and on Google
Cloud it gave businesses a secure
managed solution and it gave developers
a common development platform it was a
huge step forward but it still left one
major customer problem unsolved it
didn't make it easy for you all to span
multiple cloud providers so we've been
hard at work and we have spent the last
year developing a product that gives you
the flexibility to make the best
decisions for your business now and in
the future we think we have the answer
and I'm proud to introduce you to that
product today we call it anthos Antos
anthos is based on kubernetes
it runs on premise but it also supports
multi and hybrid cloud and Moranis and
is fully managed by Google it brings
together the simplicity of open source
platforms our deep technical expertise
and the freedom to choose the right
cloud partner for your job it lets you
write once and run your jobs anywhere in
our cloud in your data center or on
other cloud providers it gives you the
flexibility to move on from apps to the
cloud when you are ready and it allows
you to keep using the technologies
you're already using while improving
security we have built anthos to be
simple flexible and secure all the
things you'd want in a great technology
partner and thank you for giving us that
opportunity to be that partner I'm going
to turn it over to Thomas Korean to give
you all the details thomas has only been
leading Google cloud for about 10 weeks
now but many of you probably know him
from more than two decades of experience
serving enterprise customers in a short
time at Google he's already met with
hundreds of customers and partners
I think his personal productivity he's
testing the limits of G suite and
calendar he's a tremendous leader with a
powerful vision and I'm incredibly
excited to have him leading Google cloud
Thomas take it away
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much sunder and a word of
thanks to Diane Greene who spent so many
years helping build Google cloud and she
retired earlier this year and I'm very
grateful for her leadership of Google
cloud for so many years
then we at Google cloud have a very
clear vision on what we want to offer
customers in a number of industries who
are going through digital transformation
we want to give them global scale
distributed secure infrastructure a
digital transformation platform that
helps people build innovative digital
transformation solutions and then
industry specific capability for digital
transformation in a number of industries
the first important announcement we're
making here at next is anthos it came
from our listening to customers who
wanted three important things from their
cloud providers first the ability to
have a technology stack that would they
could run in their data center next to
enterprise workloads that they couldn't
yet move to the cloud hybrid cloud
second a single programming model that
gave them the choice and flexibility to
move workloads to both Google cloud as
well as other cloud providers without
any change and third a platform that
allows them to operate this
infrastructure without complexity and to
secure and manage across multiple clouds
in a single consistent way to show you
these capabilities and to talk to you in
more detail let me welcome al minore
from our engineering organization was
one of the leaders in our product
development for antle's they are
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thomas in building Google
Cloud we have heard from many of you
about the challenges you face today I'm
lucky to get to meet CEOs of large
companies often for instance a large
retail enterprise CIO recently told me
I'd like to build me a future solely
based on open source technologies that
can be cloud agnostic that is the only
way for me to reduce risk as we invest
more and more in the cloud I hear from
so many of you that you need to move
faster to stay competitive and gain an
edge time to market for products and
services has shortened dramatically from
years today's you want innovation to be
a strategic enabler for your business
the cloud promises a path forward with
new technologies managed services and
the ecosystem to help you succeed
however the reality is that managing
hybrid or multi cloud compute can be
incredibly challenging and complex today
80% of workloads are still not in the
cloud there is a very real risk of being
locked in by investing too much in a
single cloud analysts estimate that 88%
of companies are expected to adopt a
multi cloud strategy each cloud count
with its own proprietary infrastructure
proprietary and api's and that creates a
strain on your precious precious talent
and adds cost using multiple clouds
without again without a strategic plan
is a guaranteed way to increase
operational cost and fragment your
developers and operators and all of that
can just add risk and none of us are
doing this because we want more east
that's for sure to help you succeed in
this world sorry and last year at next
we introduced Google cloud services
platform our hybrid product that sundar
mentioned over the past eight months
we have partnered with some of you for
early adopters to solve these challenges
thank you for being a part of this
journey with us and thank you for our
team for all the hard work since today
we are excited to announce that this
platform Anthes is now generally
available for everyone thank you using
our platform you can build and deploy
apps rapidly both on-premise and in the
cloud with security built in you can
truly build it once and run anywhere and
there is more today we are also excited
to announce that we are embarking on the
multi cloud journey anthos is going
multi-cloud if you are using multiple
compute environments anthos is that
choice for you it lowers your IT cost
with the latest managed open source and
has security layers integrated right out
of the box with anthos you can modernize
on-premise right now you can actually
install and start running in less than
three hours it provides monitoring
logging visibility and CI CD tooling so
you can increase your developer and
operator velocity on-premise and in the
cloud in a consistent way this is the
new reality we're bringing to you you
should be able to depend on increasing
levels of automation and focus on what's
happening
further up the stack and take the
infrastructure almost for granted you
should be able to deploy new and
existing apps running on premise and in
the clouds without having to invest in
constantly retraining your developers
you can truly double down on delivering
business value not only have we built
this technology but we have worked with
multiple key ecosystem partners to bring
answers to you Google cloud and our
partners are with you every step of the
way bringing to you a platform that you
can use everywhere you need it
thank you and back to you Thomas
[Music]
thank you very much Alf as he mentioned
we've been working with a number of
partners to make sure that our customers
can interoperate these partner solutions
with Google technology it's my great
pleasure now to welcome to Google cloud
next one of our partners
David Gettler executive vice president
of Cisco Systems please give him a warm
welcome David
anytime that's how you doing welcome to
next great group you got here yes David
Cisco has built an incredible networking
and security franchise hundreds of
thousands of enterprise customers around
the world giving your scale and market
share you have the ability to engage
with a massive global customer base what
are you hearing from your customers well
look I think you guys are hitting it
exactly right here today I mean the
world has landed on hybrid cloud there's
obviously a huge amount of cloud
adoption going on not surprising the
cloud is a seminal technology trend of
our era but I think the way we've talked
about it over the last several years has
been very application centric which
makes a lot of sense
hey the application is moving to the
cloud but when you look at it from the
CIOs perspective in the enterprise
it's more of an expansion motion which
is hey now my application is moving to
the cloud I have applications still in
my data center as you've talked about
here I may have applications on the edge
of my network and now I have to connect
all of my users to these applications
and what we're finding is that's
changing the entire IT technology stack
underneath in the enterprise is having
to think about their entire
infrastructure and how do i architect
that differently for the realities of
the cloud that brings a lot of
complexity and I think it's on us as the
industry to work together to try and
push back against that complexity and
help them drive to more simplicity so
we've been working together since 2017
what's your vision for how we're
simplifying things for customers look I
mean I think this has been a great
collaboration and it started the right
way it started with an engineering led
collaboration so I remember ears and I
had a conversation back in 2017 and we
were talking about the whole adoption of
cloud and I remember urged a statement
the world needs a lighted path to the
cloud and I thought that was very
insightful because that's exactly what
we were seeing in our customers and we
have highly complementary technology
bases I mean what Cisco is all about the
franchise I run is connecting users to
applications in doing that securely and
you know all the pieces in between doing
that
Google brings unbelievable cloud
technology and kubernetes to the
equation so we thought hey can we put
our technology stacks together and
deliver a very differentiated solution
to our customers in this hybrid and
multi cloud world what makes our
partnership unique look I think it's
unique for a couple of reasons first of
all I think for it we start with the
premise of hybrid and multi cloud right
it's not about the cloud working
backwards it's about the realities of
the environment that all of our
customers live in today and then we're
going about it with a start from the
concept of very open and obviously
Google brings that Cisco brings that the
idea we need to build open ecosystems
the people around us can embrace and
extend it's not all about just our two
technologies I think those are important
technologies but we're bringing together
a technology base that's open and
extensible and our customers can take
that and drive it and help push back on
some of this complexity that's that's
coming into their network with the
adoption of cloud thank you so much
David your partnership and for your
teamwork with us all right
congratulations what you're doing here
today it's impacting the whole industry
thanks I'll take care of it so we wanted
to show you now anthos live we want to
show you how easy it is to build a
workload run it in your data center move
it to multiple clouds without a single
line of code needing to be changed let
me welcome Jennifer Lin from our product
organization to show you anthos Jennifer
[Music]
as a platform administrator you have a
difficult job you have the
responsibility of keeping your company
ahead of the competition this means
enabling your developers and helping
them deploy new applications and
features fast while keeping your
business stable and secure you're
working with existing and new
applications some on virtual machines
and increasingly others in containers
today we're eager to show you more of
anthos what we believe is going to be
the cloud platform of choice for many
years to come the platform that gives
you the freedom to do what you want how
you want and where you want and we're
here to help you
one thing that's top of mind for
everyone is migration and modernization
it's been really exciting to work with
our customers on crafting the journey
that's right for them and we want to
make sure that they have as many options
as possible so how can those help J
we're really proud to announce an
upcoming new beta anthos migrate anthos
migrate lets you modernize your
workloads
directly into containers and kubernetes
which means benefits like modern
controls lower costs more automation and
portability across clouds as if that
wasn't good enough anthos migrate will
do this VM to container conversion
automatically without requiring VM
modifications or app rewrites beforehand
that's a big big deal at Google cloud
we're all about seeing is believing so
how about a demo right now you can see a
typical deployment of VMs running on
on-prem VM where this particular VM here
is running our e-commerce site the
online boutique it's running on a VM
today but that means I T has to patch it
while trying to avoid disruption they've
got to buy more hardware to support
Black Friday and then have that Hardware
set idle for the rest of the year and
most importantly they've got to pain
stay clean protect their customer data
there's got to be a better way right
this site could benefit in so many ways
from running as a container instead
IT gets away from patch management can
deploy auto-scaling for the holiday
season and ensure the protection of
their customer data doesn't that sound
better okay let's go to cloud shell and
modernize this VM right here right now
we built a simple script that triggers
anthos migrate to begin modernizing that
on Prem VM to Google Cloud and
automatically convert it to a container
in kubernetes engine are you ready let's
execute the script off we go and it's
just that simple
this new streamlined process represents
a tremendous simplification of your
modernization journey okay
now let's see the results in the cloud
console now that this process has begun
anthos migrate will have this app
running again in just a few minutes
regardless of how big the data set is
but we don't want to keep you waiting
we've kicked off an equivalent process
just before we came on stage as you can
see here in our cloud console our
e-commerce site that was running on a VM
is now running in a container and as you
can see this is the same app but now our
customers get all the benefits of anthos
and manage kubernetes converting that VM
into a container frees up our customers
from managing infrastructure and lets
them focus on delivering business value
instead and it makes modernization
easier than you ever thought possible
this is game-changing for anyone who
thought their VMs might be impossible to
modernize now over time this same
application has been modernized as a
dynamic mesh of services talking to one
another
managing service driven applications can
be complex and modern services require
completely different access restrictions
for instance commerce services such as
procurement and order fulfillment have
very different policies than payment
processing even though both require
tight controls and audits using Google
cloud service mesh we have visibility
into all of these components and we can
focus on business agility instead of
access policies let's look a little bit
deeper into this Apps deployment
this is still the same app and it's got
a shopping cart service which you can
see here in our topology view lines are
representing permissions across the
services the shopping cart service is
being accessed by some of our partners
right now on the other hand this payment
service is restricted to only be
accessed by the shopping cart service
since we showed you this product last
year we have been working on some
innovative advancements including Google
cloud service meshes ability to deliver
real time in-depth telemetry and
security insights now you can assess the
security posture of your applications
and make proactive recommendations to
help manage risk let's take a look at
the payment service and how we can apply
security policies as you can see here
there is a security recommendation from
Google cloud service mesh to help
improve the security posture of the
payment service this policy
recomendation
once applied will authorize an encrypt
Rafic between the payment service and
the shopping cart service this is policy
driven decisions without modifying your
backends without touching your code now
let's go to the cloud shell and add
these changes into our anthos config
management repository and then commit
the changes anthos gives you unified
programmatic api's across all of your
deployments so now that we have
committed the changes the new
declarative configuration will be
applied across all environments at once
for applications running on anthos
controls are implemented by anthos
without any changes to the application
so you get to manage governance
consistently no matter where your
workloads run you can move fast and stay
agile while improving upon your security
posture everything we showed you today
is not just GCP and on Prem in fact if
you look at the console you'll see there
are three services running let's take a
look at the address of one of them it's
actually running on another public cloud
this is really big thank you
with anthos you run anywhere and not
only that you can manage services
consistently on Google cloud on Prem and
on other clouds this is exactly what I
all meant when we announced that anthos
is going multi cloud
yes so what does this mean for you if
you're a developer you get to avoid the
pain of rewriting your code just to
deploy to a new cloud as an ops person
you get the ability to consistently
manage your apps wherever they run if
you're running the business you get
leverage when you're negotiating a cloud
contract and this isn't just about your
own code it extends to software from
partners ISPs and the open source
community here you see us running anthos
to consistently deploy a cloud VC ICD
service across any environment before
anthos deploying to multiple
environments mint custom config for
every environment time wasted on
operational overhead security audits for
each new service and more now you
finally have a consistent experience to
flexibly deploy and manage services
running on GCP in your own data center
as well as on other clouds I don't know
about you but I think that's pretty cool
all right
over the last year we've been working
with many customers on their hybrid and
multi cloud transformations we just
showed you a lot let's take a step back
and look at what we saw number one
modernizing your on-prem workloads is
easier and faster than ever before to
most companies already have a multi
cloud and hybrid strategy but AB DOS is
the only platform that lets you actually
achieve that and three we understand
that every transformation is different
and Google wants to partner with you to
make sure that you achieve all your
modernization goals let's bring your
cloud and your services to life back to
you Thomas Wow Jennifer amazing job
we've seen so many partners working with
us to bring our solutions to customers
together one of these partners is VMware
a company that's used with software's
used by so many enterprise customers and
it's my great privilege to welcome
Sanjay Poonam chief operating officer of
VMware to Google next Sanjay
[Music]
I promise Sanjay great to have you at
next innovate esteem widespread adoption
of kubernetes since its inception both
of our companies are committed to
delivering hybrid cloud solutions based
on open source technologies that Google
created which are essential to modern
app development can you provide us with
more detail on how open source
technologies like kubernetes are part of
VMware strategy yeah I will Thomas let
me first say congratulations on your
role Thomas and I grew up in the same
town in Bangalore we went to rival
schools I spent eight years competing
against him when I was at sa P and
Oracle I'm just happy to be on a stage
partnering with you finally so that's
great and he's gonna do great things for
Google Cloud and your on your question
in kubernetes I think the world is
starting to realize it is a world of
containers and VMs and we have embraced
kubernetes big time at VMware we
acquired a company hep T oh that was
started by some of the founders of
kubernetes and now with Google have
become one of the top contributors to
kubernetes and what we're doing is
taking your new name Antos integrating
it with essential PKS which is a new
name for hep T oh and I'm gonna deliver
a unified solution that will be
supported by by VMware and Google
secondly we're also gonna support anthos
on vSphere our leading hypervisor and
also an essential PKS so our desires to
bring for all of you enterprise
customers the best of a virtual machine
and kubernetes containers together with
this collaboration Thank You Sanjay a
key component of the hybrid cloud is
networking all the way from the branch
office to the cloud what are we doing
together with Eska van and service mesh
yeah you know quietly many of you may
not think of VMware a networking space
for the last five or six years since
we're quite nice Sara we've become the
leader in software-defined networking
and our vision has been to take nsx the
product from the data center to the
cloud into the branch we also acquired
about 18 months a really hot company
called Velo cloud and Velo cloud has
become now in Gartner's sort of ranking
the top right in SD when it's sort of
like the name sized velocity and cloud
it does things really fast and simple so
with simple things like zero touch
provisioning a single click a dynamic
multipath
we're able to basically integrate now to
GCP so that many of you folks who have
remote offices and branch offices and
retail and banks and other places you
get the best benefits of Velo cloud
integrative natively into GCP and now
all of your applications in the branch
office has just worked faster and you're
a senior executive of the devil family
where does vmware and the broader dell
family see opportunities and working
more closely with GCP yes you know dell
is one now the public is one of the
leading hardware providers of a number
of different areas server storage
infrastructure many of the benefits we
talked about anthos running on vSphere
will extend to what's called
hyper-converged infrastructure the
x-trail and VMware's investments
software-defined storage is now number
one in that category so you'll get all
those benefits with Dell hardware dell
also has a great asset all boomy which
has become now a cloud-based data
integration leader we're integrating
that with Apogee that's part of the
Google family to bring the best of data
integration and API management which is
what people want today in this
integration world and then are not
client-side we've been quietly
innovating with a workspace one that
came from the embers acquisition of
AirWatch been doing a lot of good stuff
with you in android and chrome book
where we're now the leader in what's
called unified endpoint management but
we're going to extend that now to Google
cloud identity engine so we can bring
all that context where data into Google
Data engine so a lot of things that we
are looking forward to collaborating
with you already done and more to come
thank you so much thank you Thomas all
of the regulations so when we built
Antos we worked with a number of
hardware companies to allow our
customers who are deploying in a hybrid
architecture to use their preferred
hardware stack to run anthos we're also
grateful for a partnership with Intel
who has built a reference architecture
for anthos to make it easy for customers
to deploy our workloads on anthos on
this reference configuration finally we
recognize that you want solutions
partners and we work with a number of
and providers who complement our
technology and that of our partners as
well as services partners who can run
and manage services for you on antle's
to hear from a customer who has been
using anthos in early access please
welcome
Ratnakar Levu chief technology officer
and senior executive vice president of
caused a leading american retailer wroth
knocker
[Music]
[Applause]
uh-huh but like a welcome to next you
know as a leading retailer for over 50
years
tell us about how you and Michelle your
CEO are looking at your strategy for the
next 50 years first of all
congratulations on your new role as you
know Thomas you you and I've worked a
long time together so as the retailer
we've always been focused on the
customer customer first in today's
digital age and digital transformation
our customers are expecting seamless
frictionless experiences so that then
translated us into thinking about the
way we work we want it to be more agile
more nimble that then translated into
how we do things so why should we set up
infrastructure and other things like we
used to do before so we are now
leveraging our hybrid cloud so as part
of the hybrid cloud strategy the ability
to leverage the infrastructure in the
cloud the applications in the cloud to
bring all these experiences for that our
customers are demanding and by the way
Google anthos is the one that we chose
with all the different cloud providers
out there why did you choose Google as
your primary cloud partner as you know
Athamas retail is in the midst of major
transformation so as a retailer we
needed to innovate we also needed to
become more engineering focus and guess
what Google has that same DNA and
engineering focus driving innovation
that really kind of blended us together
in terms of this partnership and by the
way I'm super excited about that okay
thank you what are some of the benefits
that you've seen as you've migrated more
workloads to the cloud what did you
decide to keep what do you decide to
move yeah so the big benefits is as a
retailer our big thing is is the holiday
season
Black Friday tremendous amount of volume
so what we needed to do before the cloud
was we needed to get all this capacity
and that capacity used to set either
for about nine months of the year so the
cloud actually enabled us to scale to
that capacity during the holiday season
so big benefit for us and in terms of
the hybrid cloud it also gave us the
ability to be more agile using DevOps
and also to move applications and change
applications much faster so these are
some of the key benefits that we have
seen with the cloud now when it comes to
how did we decide what to actually move
and transform to the cloud we did an
extensive and exhaustive analysis of our
infrastructure and our applications and
we broke them into three parts one as
are they cloud ready
hence left hand chef are they do they
need to be redesigned for the cloud and
so we're in the process of working on
many application to make them cloud
ready and the third is should we retire
something because it's no longer
important in this new world and we've
been on this journey for three years and
I can tell you we're really excited
about what we're seeing right now great
how do you measure its success with the
transformation successes again back to
the customer it's about the customer
engagement and the sales and last Bragg
Black Friday we ran cold calm and mobile
our mobile applications and mobile web
on the Google cloud and what I can tell
you is we sustained the peak load we
actually had the best response time in
terms of the experience for our customer
and we had tremendous amount of sales so
I'm really happy with that
congratulations you're out the car thank
you for the work you and your team are
doing with our stuff so let's step back
a minute now and look at Google's vision
for cloud computing you know we see
industries around the world being
transformed with digital technology
whether that's hospitals wanting to
change how they deliver patient care
using digital the way that retailers
want to offer new experiences for
customers or financial institutions want
to attract customers in new ways we at
Google want to deliver three important
things to help customers on this journey
first global scale distributed
infrastructure second a suite of digital
transformation solutions and third
specific solutions using Google's
advanced technologies for specific
industries now for global scale
distributed infrastructure we look at
building out capabilities in Google
cloud bringing the broadening the number
of regions around the world to which we
deliver that taking that out to the
cloud edge for example for customers in
gaming in media and streaming or
distributing our broad network edge to
bring computing closer to you and now
with anthos we can bring it all the way
into your data center with hybrid cloud
or on multiple clouds for a platform for
digital transformation
we've building a capability to offer
five important solutions for customers
the ability to manage data at scale to
build and modernize application
workloads to do analysis to identify
patterns in your data and make better
business decisions as organizations to
use google's AI and m/l technology
advances and to collaborate with other
people in your organization or outside
the boundaries of your organization in
profound new ways
we're also broadening this platform to
allow partners to complement our
platform and we have some very important
announcements today with partners
finally we're building out unique
capability for specific industries which
help companies in these industries use
Google's technology advances to
transform themselves these include
organizations in healthcare in retail in
media financial services and other
industries now of incredibly proud
of the momentum we have in the largest
companies or not nine of the top ten
retailers seven of the top ten media
companies and leaders in virtually every
industry have chosen Google cloud to
help them on their digital
transformation journey now the reason
they've chosen us is because of the
capabilities that we provide one of our
most important industries is healthcare
and we're grateful for life sciences
companies patient care providers
insurance companies and others who have
used Google cloud we're super excited
today to announce a number of new
companies that are using Google cloud to
deliver healthcare in new ways one of
these customers is Phillips and it's my
great privilege to welcome Alton and
oshi group chief information officer of
Phillips to Google cloud next up
[Music]
why are you Thomas thank you for coming
it's wonderful to have you tell us about
the work that Phillips is doing globally
in health care
absolutely first of all what a pleasure
to hear about at Naz she kept it as a
well preserved secret so huge
congratulations thank you that was music
to my ears at Philips
our mission and vision is to make sure
that we improve the lives of 3 billion
people per year by 2030 and it's a it's
a target that we want to achieve with
help of of course partners like Google
and many of the other partners that you
have also mentioned and indeed when you
look at the trends in the healthcare
technology sector then it is about
digitalization to begin with the
customer centricity is very very
important you need to know the patients
you need to know the doctors the
clinicians so that is an important
aspect in the healthcare industry and we
are facing all of these challenges in
this industry while the transformation
in technology around us by the worldwide
industrial you know industry IOT devices
machine learning and AI are coming up
right behind us right so for us it is
important to meet that quadruple in
which is patient care better health
outcomes and all the related aspect
where cost of giving healthcare services
should be affordable how do you see
delivering patient care to billions of
people and how does cloud technology
really help you to deliver to that last
mile to that patient absolutely if I
look back we are a 127 year old company
and I'm sure there are many enterprises
of that nature so when I see Google for
example
I'm probably the next generation CIO you
know next next right so when they look
at it the in Philips we have a huge our
strategy is to have the digital
transformation for the legacy landscape
now what we have already done is taken
2,000 applications and put them on the
cloud now these were initially tier 2
applications now where we want to focus
on and what I believe this morning I
heard from sundar Jennifer and you also
mentioning about it is the whole aspect
of not only hybrid cloud but also
cybersecurity plays a big role and so
what is running in my mind right now is
tier 1 we talked about the year PS the
SP basis which all of our large company
in a healthcare domain is working to us
quality availability and security are
probably the most important three
criteria and that's where I look at you
know cloud playing a huge role because
we can't live with the legacy data
centers where service assurance is a
pain you need to move to cloud on-demand
quick and make it happen where do you
see AI and m/l helping you in your
transformation well what I notice is
that you know AI allows the thinking and
analysis decision-making to be quite
different than what us are capable of
without the machine learning and AI
capabilities so to us when we are doing
these non-invasive procedures the
clinics then all of the data sets that
we can have as a reference on which
machine learning and all of these data
being loaded up in the cloud and then
machine learning and AI algorithms being
applied for better decision insight to
the doctors physicians etc so even as a
patient you're well informed of what is
going on the self care become
as possible so to us in fact the aspect
that Google is indeed looking at cloud
and a combination of machine learning
and AI is actually really good because
that gives us a way not only to learn
from you all and depend on you all but
also allow for our quadruple aim as I
mentioned to happen thank you all enough
for your amazing mission as Phillips and
for your partnership with us of people
around the world with better healthcare
thank you very much thank you for coming
retail is another industry that's going
through major transformation and we at
Google have been very fortunate to work
with many of the leading retailers
around the world today at Google next
we're pleased to announce that some
brands that all of you are familiar with
have chosen us to transform how they
deliver great new experiences to
consumers around the world now financial
services isn't in it is a industry that
Google has had a long history of
collaboration with we've had many
financial institutions running on Google
cloud and using Google cloud to deliver
great new services to their consumers at
Google cloud next we're very pleased to
announce two important new customers
chase and ian's at Bank it is now my
great privilege to welcome
Reggie chambers managing director and
chief administrative officer of Chase
consumer banking to Google cloud next to
talk about how we're working together to
transform community banking Reggie
welcome to Google cloud next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for coming Reggie tell us a
little bit about yourself your role at
Chase and what you're doing to transform
community banking fantastic well thank
you so much for having me here I could
not be more excited to talk about the
things we are doing to transform the
banking industry as they are very much
aligned my personal passion in life
which is to help others all you need to
know about me is that I'm a husband and
a father of two beautiful children
Madison and Myles and like so many of
you I am passionate about trying to make
a difference in the world leaving it a
bit better than I found it and so that
the world can be a bit better going
forward for our kids our families and
our communities this is an amazing
country one where my family has gone
from being slaves sharecroppers farmers
in the segregated south to be attending
top universities serving a president in
the White House and now standing in
front of you all representing an amazing
institution like JPMorgan Chase
[Applause]
you know we are fortunate to live in the
land of opportunity where a story like
mine is possible but when we look across
America today we realize that's not true
for everyone
for many the doors of opportunity are
closed they don't have a fair shot and
what we want to do here chase we just
want to work alongside partners like
Google to change that outcome a bit we
are fortunate to have great resources as
Google and as Chase to address this
opportunity gap and that's what we want
to do today so at Chase I'm fortunate to
be a part of the leadership team that's
innovating around how we can better
serve the communities we are in we serve
our customers in our communities with
more than 135,000 employees and more
than 5,000 branches and what we're
seeing today with our customers is they
want more than more than just having a
transactional relationship with us they
want they want to have a partner who can
who can provide advice at life moments
when they need us the most and we want
to be that go-to partner together with
community organizations in Google to do
just that and we can change the bank
branch model of the future in order to
provide more opportunities for the
communities we serve can you give the
audience some examples of how we're
working to make this real absolutely I'm
excited to do that so yeah we have a
unique vision for the bank branch model
of the future we want our branches to be
destinations where people can go to get
the advice they need to lead a
financially healthy life we also want to
have branches that are Innovation
Centers where you can get the latest
technology and innovative community
programming to really deliver the next
value proposition for our customers and
our clients imagine a place where you
can go to learn how to do learn how to
code learn how learn how to set up a
small business learn how to do your
taxes learn how to get the job interview
skills that you need so you can take it
to the next level for you for you and
your family and that's what we want to
do is bring those four a data insights
and technology to that game and together
with partners like Google we're going to
turn that dream into a reality
so we are excited to announce that we
have chosen Harlan one of our nation's
most historic communities to launch this
new branch drink Bank branch model of
the future and we're excited to tell you
guys more about it in the coming weeks
and months ahead
regi along with our team at Google I'm
super pleased to partner with you what's
such a historic mission we're so proud
that we can help you as a technology
partner on this noble mission that you
and chase are embarking on thank you so
much thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
similar to what we're doing in retail in
financial services and healthcare
we're also transforming manufacturing
helping organizations optimize the
supply chain their warehouses their
distribution systems and we're very
pleased at Google cloud NEX that a
number of additional manufacturing
brands a few of them here have chosen us
to be the strategic partner on digital
transformation Google also has a long
history in telecommunications media and
entertainment nine of the top ten media
companies in the world use us to help
them a great digital content create
dynamic catalogs use our streaming
infrastructure to distribute them and
allow them to build new models for
business like direct-to-consumer these
are some of the customers who choose us
and at Google cloud next were very
pleased to announce some additional wins
of media and entertainment companies as
well as telecommunication partners who
have chosen us to help them on that
journey to the cloud finally we have a
long commitment to the public sector
we'll work with state governments
federal government agencies and
educational institutions for a number of
years this is just a tiny segment of the
many customers in public sector use
google cloud and we have many more new
customers some of which I've listed here
for you to see our work in these
industries would not be complete if we
build enterprise capability the we at
Google cloud want to be the best
strategic partner to organizations who
are choosing that digital transformation
journey and we believe that we can do
that
in two important ways the first way is
bringing expertise to help you on that
journey and the second to be the easiest
cloud provider to do business with to
help you on that journey
we're massively expanding our
go-to-market organization not just with
salespeople but with technical
specialists who deeply understand
technology and industries and can help
you in your customer success role to
build great new transformational
opportunities using our technology
foundation to make it easy for our
customers to do business with us we're
introducing a variety of new things
simplified pricing easier contracting
co-innovation frameworks where we can
work with you and partners and we
recognize partners are very very
important to Google and we're broadening
our partner reach and introducing a
number of new enhancements in our
partner program we're very grateful to
all of you our partners who have done so
much to help us further our mission to
being successful as a digital
transformation provider and we've seen a
4x growth in partner certifications this
last year of 4x growth and developer
certifications and as six times growth
in developer learning hours all
Testaments to the interest in our
technology and how it can help customers
on that journey to digital
transformation now the foundation of
this sets our data center infrastructure
Google invests enormous amounts of money
and technology skills in building the
most sophisticated data center
infrastructure in the world and here at
Google next we have a number of
important new announcements in the
capabilities we offer in the data set
we're introducing a number of important
new things to help people migrate and
modernize workloads when they shift to
the cloud with the best infrastructure
solutions for cloud computing we're
introducing new Hardware broadening the
number of regions where a cloud presence
is introducing new capabilities in
networking in Seoul tendency which gives
you isolation and in DNS peering and 40
to give you a lot more detail about some
of these capabilities and how it can
help you our customers with mission
critical workloads
please welcome Brad Calder vice
president engineering for Google cloud
Brad
[Music]
thanks Thomas so my team is responsible
for building the core infrastructure
that delivers the availability security
and performance that enterprises need
the key workload we have focused on
supporting in Google cloud is sa P when
companies look at moving mission
critical workloads to the cloud such as
s AP they need large memory machines and
last year next I announced that six
turbine and 12 terabyte virtual machines
would be coming and I'm very pleased to
announce today that we are the first to
provide 12 terabyte virtual machines yes
[Applause]
now in addition to large memory machines
s AP customers are choosing Google cloud
because of our availability security and
flexibility so let's talk about
availability when the NSA fee system
goes down business stops no financial
transactions no manufacturing no
transportation no stock your shelf
everything comes to a halt one life
sciences s AP customer said that they
lose three million in revenue per hour
when just one other s AP Systems goes
down on-premise yeah for decades s ap
enterprises have accepted downtime due
to hardware software and operating
system patches and strategies for
dealing with this tend to be expensive
and toilsome this downtime just doesn't
make any sense that is why we designed
Google cloud to virtually eliminate
downtime to keep your critical
applications running and available this
all happens transparently for you under
the covers with live migration live
migrations seamlessly migrates your VM
based applications in the work in the
background and it keeps your SP
applications up and running and open for
business even in the face of
infrastructure maintenance upgrade
security patches and more now let me
give you an example when Google
researchers discovered the specter
vulnerability
we use live migration to patch every
single GCP server with zero downtime for
our users so our customers were
protected even before they knew they
needed to be and we are the only client
cloud that uses live migration across
our fleet this help keeps your workloads
that you run on Google cloud to both
safe and available now I'd like to
welcome Hanauma and will on stage to
show you live migration in action on
asipi using our large memory virtual
machines
[Music]
let's start with an esper Hanna Eric tea
system at the top are VMs running the s4
Hana application at the bottom you can
see SAP demo HDD that's our Hana
database let's talk about how live
migration works when Google Cloud
detects a maintenance event it
immediately creates another copy of your
VM on another host one that's already
been patched once the new VM is on Kota
put the old VM it takes over its
identity and traffic this whole process
the migration from the old VM to the new
one completes in under one second right
now we're running a standard as a key
benchmark for a busy enterprise scenario
thousands of users create things his
orders running reports some more now
we're going to trigger migration using
an API that we provide by the way you
can use that if UI yourself and figure
out how your workload performs with live
migration right now in the background
GCD is spinning up another VM and
copying the data over including multiple
terabytes of memory now let's switch
over to stack driver and see what's
happening in the top left we see our
history of live migrations the one we
just started will take a moment so let's
look at some we triggered just before
the keynote started with other cloud
providers you don't get live migration
so you would have at least a 30-minute
downtime during the reboot and reloading
of all this data and if every boot was
due to a critical security vulnerability
you might not even get a choice of when
it happens someone else can be deciding
when your business is down but the
bottom left graph shows that with Google
Cloud there has been zero downtime for
the system despite the migrations as you
can see the system continued to process
more than 20,000 transactions per minute
even while it was being migrated without
live migration you have to make a
trade-off between uptime and security
but with live migration your critical
business application
stay available and secure so in summary
we've just shown you forcing a live
migration event
you saw how the system stayed fully
available through the event i running s4
hana system inside the VM on GCP
processing thousands of business
transactions we also showed you the six
and twelve terabyte the amps are now
available for early testing and we
expect them to be as if he certified by
q3 of this year thank you thanks a man
so as it gets as you saw live migration
helps keep your application secure and
security is top of mind for SI p
customers you can imagine the
sensitivity of the data inside an SI p
system financial data customer data
human resource data and more and in
terms of your DNA Google does not access
customer data for any reason other than
those necessary to fulfill our
contractual obligations and on top of
that Google Cloud is the first to offer
access transparency for your data in
case a Google cloud engineer needs to
access data for support purposes our
access transparency feature provides you
with logs of that access along with
justification as to why and only at
Google is all of your storage stored
encrypted at rest by default without you
having to do anything and if you even
want any want more control over your
data the best way to achieve that is to
add another layer of encryption over
that data with keys that you control and
manage yourself and provide this we
offer a full range of encryption
technologies integrated with our stack
this includes customer management
caption keys and solutions to manage and
protect your keys like our cloud key
management service and our Phipps
certified hardware security modules so
these are just a few ways Google cloud
helps keep your s AP financial customer
employee and other data safe and secure
so we talked about availability and
security now let's talk about
flexibility between now and 2025 s-u-v
customers have to Mike
to the latest version of ERP called s
for Hana and to do this to need lots of
pores and lots of memory now in doing
this migration it's hard for customers
to determine the exact configurations
that will be needed and it's hard to
predict how these systems will grow over
time so what s AP customers want is - is
the ability to buy a commitment for
cloud resources and have the flexibility
to allocate those resources across their
workloads as needed in Google cloud
provides the most flexibility here among
the cloud providers for example you can
buy a committed use discount and use it
across all your virtual machines to
maximize your savings without getting
locked into specific shapes and sizes I
think you can easily use that commitment
when switching from smaller to larger
VMs as your OSAP systems grow so to
recap we are pleased to now offer up to
12 terabyte virtual machines and we are
the only cloud that helps keep your
applications and your data both secure
and available with our live migration
multi-layer security and our access
transparency and we provide the most
flexibility with our committed use
discounts to prevent you from getting
locked into specific hardware as your
business grows and now I'd like to
welcome Thomas back on stage to tell you
about a customer who's moving their SAV
workloads to Google Cloud thank you
okay Thank You Brad so Google's
designing our cloud to run mission
critical workloads it's a privilege to
have a customer who's been a longtime
customer of Google and is using a
variety of different services within
Google cloud to help transform his
business please welcome Mike crow chief
information officer of Colgate Palmolive
Mike
[Music]
hi Thomas welcome thank you welcome it
might be good to start by telling the
audience how your company got started
with Google cloud certainly so first
thanks for having me Thomas Colgate
Palmolive success increasingly requires
global collaboration and in 2016 we knew
we needed to revamp our collaboration
technology we chose G suite I think our
success with G suite is well documented
so I won't go into details but in
summary we believe is a shining example
of cloud done right the reasons we chose
G suite have played out for us security
a continuous stream of innovation and
integrated architecture with all the
right layers of abstraction in order to
maximize availability and minimize
disruption how was your G suite
experience changed of all they're
thinking about cloud well we'd love to
see all of our enterprise business
applications work like G suite not all
of that is in our control but we're
moving forward with what we can control
we're increasingly taking advantage of
GCP to build analytics utilizing your
machine learning and bigquery
capabilities and we've begun to move
some of the on-premise software we run
in our data center to GCP as well you're
a huge sa P customer does your move to
the cloud include sa P yes that's
correct over 25 years we've built a
large a safety system footprint to a
point where 100% of our global revenue
runs through those systems we've really
just begun to run s ap on GC P but we do
have an early success let me talk about
one example in our Hills pet nutrition
business we have a platform we call
Hills to home when a veterinarian
prescribes our prescription diet pet
food to treat an ailing dog or cat our
platform allows the veterinarian to
enroll the pet and the pet parent in a
subscription program for the food the
pet parent also has a web and mobile
application to manage their subscription
the vet doesn't have to carry inventory
anymore the pet parent gets food
delivered to their door and we develop a
closer relationship with the pet parent
that's a success for everyone and GCP
allowed us to move fast if we had filed
our normal mo we would have
for six weeks for hardware to arrive
spend another week or two installing and
configuring everything instead we
provisioned the systems on GCP and the
next day the team could start working
we couldn't have hit the target go live
which we had which was very aggressive
without having made that decision but
it's not just about how fast we started
we also get the advantages GCP brings
security redundancy flexibility and
scale since that time we've moved past
the initial pilot we've gone into full
production and the application continues
to grow I'm so glad for the work your
team is doing with us thank you for
being a customer and thank you for all
the work you've done using Google cloud
to change Colgate and thanks to you as
well Tom thank you very much thank you
very much built on this global scale
distributed infrastructure we offer a
digital transformation platform it has
five important capabilities for the
developer community and for IT
organizations the ability to build great
apps to manage large quantities of data
to do analytics to use AI on machine
learning and to collaborate with people
today we're going to talk about what
we're doing for application development
we're introducing a number of amazing
new features for application developers
it allows you to use a cloud code to
write great applications to run these
applications using cloud run we use our
open source cloud functions framework to
deploy and manage these applications
with much greater simplicity and we've
integrated all of these tools with
popular open source offerings for
example github gitlab and others you're
going to hear a lot more about this at
the developer keynote I strongly
encourage every one of you to go to that
keynote where we're going to show you
some amazing
and cool new ways to build amazing
applications now Google has also had a
long history in building platforms that
service ecosystems so our view is that
platforms that succeed with customers
are those that enable ecosystems where
the cloud providers technology is
complemented with leading products that
customers and developers want to use the
first such ecosystem is what we're doing
in open source now Google has had a long
history of developing technology and
making it available in open source to
foster innovation by developers but
recently the open source community has
found that cloud providers are not
partnering with them but attempting to
take away their ability to monetize open
source we as Google do not believe that
that is good for customers for the
developer community or offer software
innovation as a result we have partnered
with leading open source companies to
deliver open source to our developer
community and customers in new ways
we're very pleased today to announce the
first integrated open source ecosystem
what this allows you to do as a
developer or as a customer is to use the
Best of Breed open source technology you
can procure them using standard Google
Cloud credits you get a single console a
single bill from Google we support these
along with the partners and as you grow
and use these technologies we share our
success with our partners so we're
fostering this new open source community
to ensure that open source continues to
thrive and has a vehicle to grow in this
world let's hear now from the chief
executive
officers of some of our important
partners about why this matters so much
to the world to the developer community
and to the ecosystem when you change
infrastructure it's very much akin to
changing the infrastructure in a city
it's no small undertaking when there's
already buildings that exist that's why
we turn to Google cloud as a partner
[Music]
when I talk to customers the common
theme I hear from every customer is they
want to be able to innovate more quickly
but the data landscape is more
complicated than it used to be people
need to actually bridge between all
these different systems all the devices
all the mobile apps all the things in
your world that are generating millions
billions trillions of transactions in
the past that used to be all stored in
databases that were great that's storing
structured data but really bad at
storing how data was related and as
people now start moving workloads from
on-premise to the cloud they have to
start thinking about what is the
database they want to run this workloads
on with Google Cloud you get the
advantage of being able to access a
tremendous amount of ML ai capability
and other services and data centers in
many many many locations all around the
world that enterprises could never
afford on their own this is all about
real time streams of events and how can
you harness all the streams of data they
have while they're interacting with the
customer
I started elasticsearch on my own and
there was no way that a single person
will be able to successfully create such
a tool with such a level of adoption
without open source the richness of that
ecosystem opens up this whole
marketplace of data systems that you can
take advantage of and the key
constituent to do that is the developer
being able to select the technologies
that enable them to innovate as quickly
as possible and that's where Google
really really have something special
evolve the way they think about this
problem set is very builder developer
oriented which is unique among the major
cloud providers enable the collaboration
of the person that produces a software
and the person that consumes the
software whenever you collapse these two
together that's where magic happens
putting all these open source companies
in one place as a really smart strategy
the customer can go to one place and get
best-of-breed solutions with a unified
experience this partnership is about
just the next generation of open source
companies building these increasingly
smarter systems things that may have
seemed insurmountable just a few years
ago now become eminently possible Google
is actually the fastest growing part of
our cloud business today and we think
we're just scratching the sir
[Music]
[Applause]
the chief executive officer of Redis
labs over Bengal is here please give him
a warm welcome and he'll tell you more
about our partnership and what it means
to his company offer
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome welcome offer tell us a little
bit about radius labs and your
partnership with Google cloud sure so
first firstly thanks for having me it's
a great event so our partnership goes
back to 2014 when we first launched
Reddy's Enterprise or fully managed
ready service on the Google cloud and
this partnership have evolved as evolved
significantly ever since we always
shared with Google the belief that our
customers and asked can greatly benefit
from our investments in the open source
community what are your thoughts about
this strategic initiative we announced
today
well this strategic initiative is great
for us because as you know monetizing
open source was always a very big
challenge for open source vendors and
more so in the cloud era now Google has
taken a very different approach from
other cloud vendor when it comes to open
source and I think that this is great
news for the open source community but
no wonder I mean Google has deep roots
in open source for years with
investments in projects like tensorflow
kubernetes etc but I think that today
with this initiative you took it to the
next level how do you think this
partnership can benefit our joint
customers so so I think that customers
can now consume radish Enterprise which
is our managed service with the same
user experience as they have with other
native Google cloud services and when I
say save user experience I mean the same
style UI same support same billing etc
etc so now they can select for certain
use cases native cloud services by
Google cloud and then for other use
cases they can select Best of Breed
enterprise-grade services by third-party
providers like Redis Enterprise and in
the case of radish I think
that you know when it comes to certain
use cases users can select cloud memory
store which is the negative ready
service by the google cloud and then for
more advanced for more sophisticated use
cases such as active active gear
distribution for readies or Redis as a
multi modal database they can go for
Eddie's Enterprise I'd like to point out
that raddish enterprise is tightly
integrated with some of the cutting edge
technologies of the Google cloud so for
example our active active gear
distribution leverages the fast global
network of the Google cloud and through
time and our readies of Flash technology
is tightly integrated with nvme and
persistent memory offerings by the
Google cloud so all in all I think it's
a match made in heaven you so much
chauffeured thank you for your
partnership thank you for what your
company and your developers are doing
with us great pleasure thank you very
much
if you're trying to imagine how would
you as a developer or a customer
experience this solution let me welcome
go polish orc from our product
organization to come up and show you
this in action Gopal
[Music]
Thank You Thomas as Thomas mentioned we
want our customers building applications
on open source to have choice the choice
of using Google managed open source
service or value-added services from our
open source partners let's take the
example of the New York Times they have
an application that requires a highly
available reticences but they also have
use cases that can benefit from Redis
enterprise features like geo distributed
cache wouldn't it be great if New York
Times can use both cloud memory store
and read a center price and have a
seamless experience between the two with
this announcement we are enabling just
that so let's take a look at few of the
elements of the experience number one
unified support Google will provide the
first line of support for all these
services number 2 unified billing
you'll get one single bill from Google
across all the Google and partner
services and number 3 unified experience
a seamless product experience where you
can use the same management tools for
both Google and partner services so
let's take a look at the product
experience we are making it very easy
for you to discover partner services as
you can see in the Google console we are
listening all the various partner
services on the Left map along with the
Google services let's say to look at
Redis enterprise as an example here you
see the solutions page where you get all
the information about the service you
can enable the API or you can manage it
let's click on manage here you see the
list of all the Redis enterprise
clusters that we have already created
but let's take a look at what the
experience looks like when you create a
new Redis Enterprise cluster the
creation flow is built directly into the
Google Cloud console so as a customer
you don't have to go to an external
partner portal to provision the service
over here you can select Redis
Enterprise features like Redis on flash
select GCP settings like regions and
networks let's go to add a database to
the cluster if you have applications
that requires capabilities like surge or
graph you can now add Redis Enterprise
modules while creating the database
click create you have a Redis enterprise
cluster created directly from the cloud
console as you can see the experience is
exactly the same as you would get with
other cloud services Google cloud
services like cloud
sequel or a cloud memory store
provisioning is just a start
you can also manage the Redis enterprise
cluster from the console let's take a
look at one of the clusters that we
already provisioned here you see the
list of databases that is that is in the
cluster the status of the database the
properties etc but let's double click
into one of the databases over here we
give you all the information about the
database but more importantly you can
monitor Redis enterprise directly from
the console so now you have a unified
management plane that allows you to
manage and monitor both Google services
and partner services it doesn't end
there if you want advanced monitoring
you can use stackdriver
over here we have created a stackdriver
dashboard that gets metrics directly
from the Redis enterprise database and
lastly if you have questions about any
of these you can call Google support
that's right a single point of contact
for support in summary when you're
building applications using open source
on GCP you now have choice the choice of
using Google manage open source services
or value-added services from our open
source partners delivered to you with a
unified support billing and product
experience thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Gopal so when you came to
Google cloud next this morning you
probably never thought you would see the
ability to build a workload run it in
your data center and have that workload
be moveable to Google cloud or any other
public cloud provider with zero change
anthos when you came to Google cloud
this morning Google cloud next you
probably did not expect to see all the
innovations were introducing an
infrastructure the only cloud that
allows you to run mission-critical
workload like sa P on a virtual
environment which gives you better
security better performance better
reliability and lower risk when you came
to Google cloud next this morning you
probably never thought that you could
use the Best of Breed open source
technology as a developer using Google
cloud credits and that Google would
share our success with these partners so
that you can continue to innovate using
these technologies these are just three
examples of great new things we're
introducing in Google cloud over the
next two days we have a host of other
announcements tomorrow in the keynote
and in many sessions today not only will
you hear about all the great things that
we're introducing and that partners are
introducing we're going to have over 400
customers talking about how they have
used Google cloud to change their
business and how they are succeeding in
using it as a platform to enable digital
transformation I hope the next two days
will be a great time for all of you to
learn about these technologies and how
they can help you
transform your organization we have a
lot of sessions today for those of you
who are watching on streaming please
continue to watch because we will
continue to broadcast on the streaming
network a number of sessions today and
tomorrow thank you very much and a warm
welcome to the to our crowd event thank
you
[Music]
you